chile es la quinta economía más grande
de latinoamérica la nueva administración
chilena debe enfrentar una inflación
histórica un descapitalizado sistema de
pensiones y los mayores índices de
desigualdad de la región la inflación es
superior al 6% el doble de la meta del
banco central chileno durante la
pandemia el producto interno bruto se
contrajo un 5,8 por ciento y fue la
mayor caída en cuatro décadas la
pandemia hizo que se permitiera el
retiro anticipado de los fondos de
pensiones el país se aprobó hacerlo tres
veces que representaron unos 48.000
millones de dólares chile que es pionero
en latinoamérica en la capitalización
individual ha sido ampliamente criticado
por el manejo de estos fondos de
pensiones por las bajas jubilaciones
pero el crecimiento económico superior
al 17 por ciento es producto de los
precios del cobre y las ayudas públicas
a los hogares que brindó el gobierno así
como el efectivo que empujó el retiro
masivo de los fondos de vejez chile el
mayor productor mundial de cobre el
litio y yodo mostró un aumento del 35
por ciento del valor de exportaciones de
cobre en noviembre las valorizaciones de
los envíos del metal rojo representaron
4000 220 millones de dólares pero no
todas son buenas cifras la pobreza se
situó en 10 8% durante el 2020 lo que
representa a 2,1 millones de personas
mientras que la pobreza extrema alcanzó
el 43 por ciento de la población la
desigualdad ha sido extrema en los
últimos 120 años incluso después del fin
de la dictadura de augusto pinochet
según world inequality lab apenas el 1%
de la población posee casi la mitad del
total de la riqueza del país la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico ocde afirma que
chile es uno de los países más
desiguales de la región tan sólo por
detrás de costa rica pero al mismo
tiempo es la nación que más quiere que
el estado reduzca su nivel de
desigualdad